let's make the world's spiciest
hamburger
hey guess what burger show is back
this might light the whole room up
season six is here and we're packing in
more burgers
and more special guests i feel like i
just gave satan a deep throat blow job
yeah i do feel that that is a tasty
burger
salt bae say hello to cheese bacon we're
bringing the heat baby
ghost pepper trinidad scorpion we're
pushing the limits at all costs
he pulled a bone out of my sandwich
we're gonna recreate
the steamed ham one of the biggest memes
on the internet
we got new faces and some old friends
too we're gonna do some time travel
welcome to georgie burger what can i get
you layers of meat
pockets of cheese i'm actually surprised
at how good this one is it's like a bad
astro strip
uh-oh problem ouch i'm covered in grease
i never said it would be perfect
ramekin size affects millions of men
every year
so this is very hallucinogenic burger
i'm gonna make a smash burger the way
they would have done it 120 years ago
let's do this we're steaming hamburgers
like a couple of true sociopaths
man i miss this so much burger show
burger show the burger show tune in the
burger show
season six get ready
you